what's going on guys this is Rob and you
guys have been asking me to cover Time
Eater Kang who's just a ridiculously
overpowered version of Cain the
Conqueror one of the many variants that
exist out there so this takes place in
the first story arc called test of time
from Exiles volume 3 and it's the only
good story out of the whole run of
Exiles volume 3 but this initially opens
up with a guy called the Unseen who's
met by a younger version of Nick Fury
we'll explain who the Unseen is later on
in this video because it will be kind of
importance he is an interesting
character but not overly important what
is important here is this younger
version of Nick Fury shows up here with
the Talis now the Talis is an artifact
that does have a great big huge lengthy
history the time broker the time
Breakers the Crystal Palace all that
kind of stuff the long and short of it
and to really kind of keep this video on
track the Talis is a device that allows
those who have it in their possession to
jump between realities but the kicker
about this is to travel from one
Universe to another is to travel through
both time and space so you could leave
the main Marvel Universe at 6:00 p.m. on
a wday and when you jump to another
reality it's like 8:00 a.m. on a
Saturday because time does not pass the
same in every single Universe because
different universes came into existence
at different points in time but with the
arrival of the Talis back in the main
Marvel Universe and it arriving on the
moon it immediately contacts blink and
the reason why is because blink was one
of the original members of the Exiles so
she very much has a close and tight
connection with the tals and so when she
gets to the moon and she comes across
the Unseen who she's never met before
he's super cryptic in his responses
right like when she asks who are you
he's like I have had names but now I am
no one now I am only an I call me the
Unseen and he just keeps on babbling on
and she's like yeah cool whatever man so
like what am I doing here right why is
the Talis here and while the Unseen
seems to indicate that it has some
understanding of the Talis which it does
due to the fact that the Talis is
multiversal and the Unseen sees
everything across the Multiverse its
response is I did not summon you here
the Talis summoned you here of its own
volition then it immediately bonds to
Blink and it Yanks her into a different
Universe now one of the things you guys
are going to notice about this is that
unlike the original Exiles Comics we're
not really getting like numerical
designations for these different
realities that the Exiles are jumping in
and out of that was kind of an important
aspect of the old school Exiles Comics
but it's not like World Tour where they
go and visit like 2099 and future
imperfect and these different alternate
realities there but what is going on
just by context of what we're seeing is
that this universe is very similar to
Days of Future Past and most all of you
guys are aware of what Days of Future
Past is on some level so we don't have
to go super in-depth into it the long
and short is that it's just a future in
any one particular Universe where where
everything just went sideways right
superheroes were either captured or
destroyed or a combination of both
Sentinels took over North America and
some realities the Sentinels took over
the world but ever since the original
Days of Future Past that kind of story
has been popular I love it right death
destruction and Mayhem I'm like
yeah give me more of that but it's just
one of these things where stuff has gone
sideways incredibly fast blink is
overpowered relatively quickly then
she's brought to an older version of
Kamala Khan who basically never became a
mutant seemingly never joined the X-Men
she's been an inhuman this entire time
now I say that because at the time this
story was written the Marvel Cinematic
Universe had not introduced Kamala Khan
to the MCU and they had not made her a
mutant so they didn't really Force
Marvel Comics to do that as well she's
just an inhuman that's out there but the
long and short of this is that she just
kind of sees herself as an enemy of like
Sentinels and so on and the world has
broken down in such a way way to where
it's just like Warlords and Petty strong
men who are just kind of ruling
different sections of whatever territory
they happen to occupy she happens to
occupy New Jersey because that's where
her character is based out of but of
course because of the fact that she
isn't human and because of the fact that
she can basically use her abilities in
terms of grabbing people detecting their
heart rates and so on and so forth and
being able to figure out whether or not
they're lying when she asked the
question of blink why are you here and
blink's response is I have no idea why
I'm here all I know is that this
Talisman just yanked me from my
Dimension into this alternate Dimension
kamalak Khan realizes she's telling the
truth but before anybody can get any
other questions the entirety of the
universe is just wiped away like
literally just annihilated like that
right it's just gone and it's like okay
so like this is nuts but the Talisman
whisks both blink and Cala away to what
is potentially and most likely a
different reality where you have iron
lad who isn't really a superhero but
he's a guy who's basic basically taking
out his bullies now for those you guys
who don't know who Iron lad is it gets
explained perfectly because what he says
is yes like Kane the conquer is me or
I'm him however you want to look at it
and so what he says is like I'm King the
Conqueror when Kane the Conqueror was a
teenager and king from the future came
into the past to rescue me from some
bullies and the Hope was that he could
start me on the path of becoming him so
it would make it easier for him to
conquer all things in existence that
origin right there is the origin of iron
lad in every single depiction of his
character that matters in Marvel Comics
this is an alternate reality version of
the character but in the main Marvel
Universe it's the exact same thing the
only difference here is that this iron
lad just chose to get revenge on his
bullies in the main Marvel Universe Iron
lad joined the Young Avengers and became
a superhero but that origin is universal
right for those you guys who aren't
familiar with that iron lad is a teenage
version of King who decided he didn't
want to become king although he
inevitably will become king Kan the
Conqueror is Kane the Conqueror right
the guy from the 31st Century who's
always going into the past and trying to
conquer everything and failing and IM
Morse is the guy that Kang will become
right Kain the Conqueror imem mortis and
iron lad explained in 15 seconds so the
thing about this is that of course Kang
in this universe shows up and starts
attacking everybody only for him to be
wiped out in like an instant and then we
end up coming face to face with the Time
Eater which is just like this giant head
of Galactus that just rolls in here and
just starts consuming the entirety of
time in this universe now this is not
Galactus just FYI right this is not
Galactus but Galactus is associated with
what's going on here now of course iron
lad and then blink and Kamala are yanked
out by the Talis just in time to keep
their entire existence from being
eradicated then they end up arriving in
Another Universe where serer is
launching some attack against like
Asgard and Valkyrie shows up to rescue
the day which is dope because Valkyrie
never gets enough respect in Marvel
Comics and and I'm glad to see that it's
finally happening right whether it's
Brun hild right or whether it's this
Valkyrie it doesn't matter Valkyrie as a
character is dope especially in the old
school Defenders Comics you guys
remember that man the OG Defenders I
know most of you guys don't most of you
guys are too young but the OG Defenders
with Valkyrie were dope in any event
blink and Kamala and them showing up
here basically kind of helped to turn
the tide of the battle serter defeated
he just runs away babbling some stuff
about how you haven't heard the L of him
and so on and so forth but much like
what we've seen so far before anybody
can get to know anybody else suddenly
everything is wiped out again right like
the Time Eater shows up and consumes
everything yet again and so as you can
probably tell a team is basically coming
into formation here and that's usually
how it works when it comes to the uh to
the Exiles for example like the next
Universe they show up to is more or less
like a cartoon style Universe Xavier's
playtime fun school for gifted
youngsters which kind of sounds
horrifying to be honest with you guys
you've got wolver rain here who's
basically this reality's version of like
spiderham right very much just kind of
like a cartoon type character but again
as we've seen before the entirety of the
universe is completely and totally
obliterated say for this little cartoon
version of wol rain who they call wolvie
who's basically brought along on the
team as well and so with this team
assembled they arrive back on the moon
and they're met with the Unseen now
here's the thing about the Unseen
because when this is happening he's
being put on trial by The Watcher right
back away from this comic book for a
second let's talk about a storyline in
Marvel Comics called Original SC so as
most of you guys know the Watcher exists
in Marvel Comics as a guy that sees
everything the way that this was
explained in Marvel is that everything
The Watcher sees is stored in the
Watcher's eyes and that in effect the
Watcher had seen something he wasn't
supposed to see and where initially the
story was a mystery we ended up learning
Nick Fury killed him the old school like
white guy Nick Fury he killed the
Watcher in response for this once the
rest of the Watchers had learned what he
done they basically imprisoned him on
the moon to replace the Watcher and he
was called the Unseen that by and large
no one really knows he's there right
even people who show up won't
necessarily see him all the time and
whether or not he is seen and by anyone
particular person it's quite literally
based on the plot I'm not even lying to
you right like there's been instances of
characters showing up and they just
never seen him right he's just there and
they just never really acknowledge his
existence but that's kind of his curse
right and so that's why him intervening
and then basically speaking to the
younger version of himself who came
through that portal with a Talis at the
beginning of all of this he's being put
on trial by the Watchers because
Watchers are not supposed to intervene
with u The Watcher it was a special case
because it's AI The Watcher and he's
awesome right who's going to tell that
guy know but as far as uh the Unseen
goes he doesn't hold that level of clout
the ker about all this is that because
of what's going on the Watchers intend
to pass judgment which means killing the
Unseen Wy goes to jump in the way blink
teleports jumps in the way knocks wolvy
out and then the blast from the Watchers
hits the Talisman and because it cracks
it just sends everybody all over the
place right they all kind of get
scattered to these different locations
literally just yanked through the time
stream arbitrarily they don't know where
they're going they don't know how
they're teleporting from one place to
the next how it's being done nothing
that you really see here in terms of
them jumping from one Universe to the
next is overly important I will say one
of the things that happens that's really
cool here is they're actually teleported
to a reality where Peggy Carter becomes
Captain America this was published in
2008 technically this character is based
on the introduction of Peggy Carter as
Captain America from Marvel Puzzle Quest
but it predates the wha if story right
so for those of you guys who believed
that the Marvel wha if cartoon was like
the first Canon appearance of Peggy
Carter becoming Captain America that's
not true and this this one is actually a
lot cooler they do help her basically
defeat the Red Skull but again the Talis
is just kind of yanking them through
from one reality to the next so it's not
really designed to bolster the roster of
the team anymore it's really just kind
of designed to have them just yanking
through different dimensions and for us
to see different Universal possibilities
but like none of it's overly important
and none of it's really cool to be
honest with you guys but eventually what
ends up happening here is they arrive
back on the moon to find that these
Watchers have all basically been
eradicated and a giant helmet of
Galactus is just kind of sitting out
there more so than that what iron lad
figures out is he says I Found Records
right he says I'm finally piecing this
whole thing together the man who killed
these Watchers also killed Galactus some
world's version of galatis and then
harnessed his power he's stolen
galactus's power a bunch of times maybe
thousands of times and he somehow turned
it into power to consume whole realities
the man who tried to kill us when we
first met the man who will consume the
last reality if we don't stop him and
that's what everybody realizes one this
is the final reality in the entirety of
the Multiverse every other Universe has
been consumed and the person doing this
is some variant of Kane the Conqueror
who killed his own universe's version of
galatis stole his power Cosmic and then
jumped to another reality did the exact
same thing and by amplifying his power
several times over it's made him
powerful enough to travel through the
entirety of the Multiverse and start
consuming whole universes wiping them
all out now in terms of what his
motivation is honestly Marvel's just
kind of pointing to the idea that like
he's just a bad guy doing bad gu stuff
and for those of you guys who are going
to ask the question where's like the
Living Tribunal in the midst of all of
this this is one of those stories that
Marvel creates where there's some
multiversal threat out there and they
just don't intervene with the Living
Tribunal because the reality here is it
was in the story in an instance there
would be no story here the Living
Tribunal would just show up and just be
like I judge against you Kang strip him
up all of his power set everything back
to the way it's supposed to be game over
right you wouldn't be able to tell this
story if you invoked the Living Tribunal
so that's why he's not here and most
likely and possibly even dead not 100%
sure but when the group goes to attack
Time Eater King nothing they do works
here nor would you expect it to right
because in reality they're just not
powerful enough to be able to defeat
this guy even when younger Nick Fury
shows up now this is when the paradoxes
start kicking in because the younger
Nick Fury that we see here this is
before he showed up on the moon and met
the Unseen at the beginning of this
story it's one of those cyclical things
where it's almost kind of a time Loop to
a degree and so as they're jumping
through they teleport to the only place
they can which is just away from that
version of Time Eater Kang but it's
still in this particular universe and
it's still in the castle of Kang because
there's nothing left there's nowhere to
teleport to that is one of the benefits
of blink when she was on the uh the
Exiles instead of just teleporting from
one geographic location to the next on
Earth or in the universe she could
teleport between realities so that
really amped and really Amplified the
abilities of her character now this is
where things also get a little bit murky
because Marvel doesn't really give us a
hard answer here which is to say if
we're going to defeat This Time Eater
King and we're going to set everything
back to right and this is all kind of
like a Time Loop how do we break the
loop we don't really get a hard answer
here instead it's all just kind of
speculating nobody really knows for sure
and a lot of that's because with this
particular Exiles team they don't really
fully understand what's going on now
that was one of the benefits of the
Exiles comics and it's one of the
reasons why I love the Exile Comics back
in the day it wasn't like your
traditional Avengers story where it was
like harken theas can the Conqueror has
travel from the future to attack us pray
tell your motivations King the Conqueror
right it's like I'm here because I'm
King and I just want to snare and ens
slay the entirety of the the Earth okay
get him and then like King's defeated he
flees Back to the Future roll credits it
wasn't like that with the Exiles in a
lot of instances the Exiles would just
be thrown into some situation and they
would have no clue what in the world was
going on but they would have to kind of
like figure out some method of finding a
way to win and they were flying by the
seat of their pants 90% of the time it
was
amazing I loved the old Exiles Comics
they were just so great and so that's
why iron lad speaks up here and he says
unless I'm exceedingly way off your
meeting with the Unseen at the start of
all of this was basically one of these
like tipping points and he says I think
if we can get the Talis back to when you
first touch this new manifestation of it
it might reverse Kang's consumption of
the Multiverse is there any evidence to
point to the fact that this might work
not really no one knows if it will they
could literally just like find some way
to use the Talis to to jump back into
the past and then go back to the very
moment when all this kicked off and
nothing changes right like everything
just continues on the way that it always
did so there's no hard and fast answers
here that kind of mindset when it came
to Exile stories is the reason why I
always said either you love the Exiles
or you hate the Exiles there is no in
between there's no middle ground when it
came to that comic and so in the midst
of them kind of pondering all of this
and asking this question they're
suddenly set upon by the return of Time
Eater King who's looking to destroy the
all now one of the cool things this
asked here is why doesn't he just kill
us right like if this guy is so
astronomically powerful why doesn't he
just eradicate us all on the spot and
call it a day and what's theorized here
which I would argue is probably the most
logical situation because we're not
really given any meaningful explanation
into the mindset of Time Eater Kang but
it's simply just as we know Kang as a
character this guy loves the idea of
taking his time and just kind of
surgically conquering universes and so
if this guy really is just a version of
Kang which he is he would take his time
in surgically consuming universes so
wiping out the last remnants of the
universe and enjoying the process of
destroying everything he would Savor all
of this right it's like being served a
fantastic stake you're not going to like
woof the whole thing down you're going
to savor it right you're going to be
like yes this 16o ribeye crusted on the
outside tender on the inside because I'm
a rational human being and I don't do
medium or medium well or God forbid well
done right like it's one of those things
where he's just kind of savoring it all
right which by the way I don't mind if
you eat your steaks you know it's medium
medium well well done right we can all
be winners so the thing about this is
that as they're jumping
through as they're jumping through right
they actually end up coming across
Sabertooth who's kind of just been long
lost in the Exiles Comics now he does
have a whole history there to keep this
video on track we're not going to go
overly into it if you guys are
interested in me covering the Exiles let
me know because the original Comics were
great they weren't that dissimilar from
this but they really were awesome and
they were certainly a lot more organized
than this story is but as they're
jumping through and even when they get
to where saber-tooth is at in this
alternate reality where everything's
frozen over this just giant head of King
the Conqueror emerges with all these
kangs multiplying like rabbits jumping
out right like literally just jumping
out and attacking all of them so like
they're fighting this Army of KS but
they have to buy time and so Kamala Khan
ends up activating this self-destruct
device and blows up seemingly all of
them buying enough time for Blink
saber-tooth and Nick Fury to jump
through the portal now when that happens
they end up just kind of arriving in
different locations right traveling to
different destinations but Nick Fury
himself travels back to when he first
met the Unseen at the very beginning of
the story for Blink herself when she
travels through she ends up at a kind of
Nexus point of realities which is to say
every possible version of herself that
can exist and when that happens she
starts marshalling forces and so she
literally brings into this fight with
all these different iterations of Kang
and even like Time Eater King fighting
like millions of versions of Kang she
brings in every single version of
herself and even just like all these
different reality beings from across the
Multiverse that all attack Time Eater
King and one Fell Swoop and while it's
not enough to like destroy him per L it
is enough to basically send him into a
retreat because what's said here is is
the Tyrant truly dead then and the
response dead unlikely he's K but gone
for now yes and I don't think he'll ever
be able to draw on this power again so
is traditional C the Conqueror just out
there in the Multiverse somewhere just
doing his thing but we'll never see Time
Eater King because he'll never be able
to gain that level of power again as far
as the question of why I don't know
because marble just decided that he
never what this is one of those things
where like there aren't really any hard
and fast answers to like why stuff's
happening it's just things are happening
because they're happening because it's
the Exiles and stuff just happens in the
Exiles comics and like that's it I
personally enjoy it I think it's fun but
let me know what you guys think down in
the comment section with that being said
guys we're going to bring this to an end
thank you all for watching and I will
catch you all later peace